normand a fait une erreur de jeunesse
ils paient encore pour cette erreur
aujourd'hui et voudrait obtenir son
pardon pour faire suspendre son casier
judiciaire cherche comment s'y prendre
et il trouve et il tombe sur un site qui
lui offre de suspendre son casier
judiciaire
un représentant de rappel rapidement
plus du service 500 $ que normand
s'empresse de payer mais le temps passe
et il ne reçoit toujours pas de décision
en plus on lui demande de payer des
frais supplémentaires
normand finit par s'inquiéter finalement
ils téléphonent la commission des
libérations conditionnelles du canada y
apprend que des organisations sur
internet ressemble à s'y méprendre au
site du gouvernement
mais c'est de la fraude seule la
commission des libérations
conditionnelles du canada accorde une
suspension du casier le symbole de
l'histoire
soyez vigilants ne confiez pas votre
demande de pardon à des criminels